what if this never ever happened again -
you're beautiful smartphone screen what
if there was a completely shatterproof
smartphone well that's just what
Motorola's promising with its new Droid
turbo - seriously
Motorola's five point four inch shatter
shield screen has five layers of
protection which it guarantees prevents
it from shattering when you drop it or
that's the claim
somebody's gotta test it test one the
concrete drop or 20 yes I dropped the
phone 20 times 10 times from 5 feet and
then another 10 times from 10 feet
well many truth
some dents and scratches around the
edges but amazingly no cracks
screen-test to the high heel step not
the most conventional test but who
doesn't want to step on a phone with all
their weight in a three inch stiletto
moment of truth wholly shatterproof
screen there is no crack where the heel
hit the screen that's insane
it's totally insane test three the
baseball bat of course I had to please
don't try this at home
seriously do not try this at home moment
of truth
not a crack in the screen it is pretty
amazing except the phone doesn't turn on
anymore okay no the droid turbo - isn't
completely indestructible but if you're
beating your phone with a baseball bat a
crack screen is the least of your
problems did I mention that when this
thing was working the 21 megapixel
camera took some really good shots and
the battery life was great but the 630
dollar price and the fact that you can
only get it at Verizon break something
it breaks my heart